Okay so
what were the big ideas of this lesson?
Well one idea is that good algorithms
are work optimal and have low span,
imagine that a DAG is a person where
dependencies go from head to toe.
Now a good algorithm is a person who has
low mass and is short, and really wide,
rather than being say really massive,
super tall and super skinny.
Our related idea is the concept
of weak scalability.
To see if you understand this concept,
here's an exercise.
Go and read about this thing called
Amdahl's Law which you might already
know about a different udasity course.
Then ask yourself, self, what's the
relationship between Amdahl's Law and
this weak scalability concept?
A second big idea in this lesson is
divide and conquer which you know and
love from sequential computing and
it's an excellent tool and paradigm for
thinking about parallel
algorithms as well.
Now in your toolbox of algorithmic
tricks it should often be the first
thing you try.
The last big idea is to separate how
you express concurrency from how you
execute it.
Now this is a really neat idea,
which makes it possible to
get truly elegant algorithms.
Unfortunately, this model
also ignores communication,
which it turns out is absolutely
necessary to be vast and scalable.
At least once the problem size and
system size get big enough.
To model communication, you're going to
need some other abstract models.
But for now, let's just see how far
we can take dynamic multi threading.